foreign
Dallas Texas what's up Chris
hey Dr John how's it going partying dude
what are you up to
oh nothing much thank you for taking my
call I really appreciate it absolutely
brother what's up man how can I help
all right so my question is how can I
best support my fiance
um with her uh bipolar
diagnosis while also still taking care
of myself and making sure that I'm good
mentally
[Music]
yeah what are y'all going through
it all started last year we've been
together five years so starting last
year
um we had pretty rough year
um
started off we lost my dad to cancer
um back in February of last year and
then
um fast forward to May
she graduated college
you know doing good looking for jobs and
then she started getting just really
really depressed like couldn't get out
of bed
um she ended up going into a manic
episode
and
ended up wanting to hurt herself we had
to hospitalize her for 10 days
and you know she's they got her
stabilized she got out and
for
probably the next four or five months
she just had little episodes about every
couple of weeks
um
I ended up quitting my job to stay home
with her
take care of her make sure she you know
didn't go out and do anything that was
going to hurt her or anything like that
and I mean that was
really really tough on me a lot of
things happen we got into a lot of
fights and you know a lot of things were
said and it was just really really tough
on me
um a lot of things you said a lot of
stupid stuff or she said a lot of stupid
stuff to you now it was a lot of mostly
I mean
that was the first time that I had dealt
with that that was the first time I went
through that with her hold on hold on I
want you to hear be I want you to pay
close attention to your distancing
language
some tough things were said
that absolves people from hurt either
you hurt somebody
and you don't like who you became in
those moments trying to take care of her
or you didn't know she was capable of
saying some of that stuff and she hurt
you what was it
uh I mean uh honestly it was a lot of
both of us
um
we both said a lot of things and did a
lot of things that you know hurt each
other and
um you know it's for me it was hard to
kind of decipher you know whether that
was actually her saying those things to
me
and that you know like I said that was
the first time I went through that and
that was just it's hard to hear a lot of
those things and so I
reacted not in the best way to it okay
and
so yeah I mean that was exactly on both
of us so are you back at work
yeah so I started a new job
um I ended up you know having a hard
time finding a job
um you know I was at home for almost
four months after that after she's found
a job and you know things went back to
normal
well fast forward to about three weeks
ago
um she was in a new job for about two
months it was her dream job
she loved it it was pretty abnormal
hours
[Music]
and they kind of forced her out
they the girl that was her boss just
didn't really want her there and then
kind of gave her the option to either
leave or stay in a toxic work
environment so we talked about it
I want to make sure we're on where that
we're
using affirmative language okay and I'll
tell you at the end while it's important
in this current market where it's very
very hard to find employees
right
it's been my experience that people are
reticent to just like I don't like her
I'm just gonna be mean to her and try to
force her out
or can you with like clear cleaning your
glasses and looking objectively
is there a chance that your fiance was a
terrible employee she didn't show up on
time she snapped at people she had
little miniature episodes at work and it
was just too much
um I mean I don't think she was a
terrible employee I think it was a
learning curve for her okay she was new
to this industry and she was learning
and she wanted to learn and they kind of
just put her in a position
that you know she either learned it on
her own or you know it didn't work out
and
I I don't think it had anything to do
with her being a bad employee
um but she but she clearly she wasn't
able to get the job but they wanted done
done
yeah yes
um
realistic expectations out of her
okay and I'll I'll say I mean yeah
ultimately here's the deal you can't
um
as much as you want to and you're a good
guy you can't fix her
right
um
I would recommend with all of my heart
not trying to fix the quote-unquote
bipolar
but instead focusing on how can I love
her and support her while she addresses
the behaviors that makes her life more
difficult
exactly if you try to go after bipolar
that's a moving Target different people
will diagnose you with different things
and bipolar one ah well the hypomania is
a little bit low so we're going to roll
you off to bipolar too the meds are just
throwing spaghetti at the wall sometimes
and so
there's a lot of toggling and a lot of
fixing and if you can get somebody who
is truly bipolar one uh in bipolar two
two but to to take their meds
you can see some extraordinary success
yeah and it's still going to be lows and
still going to be Highs but it does make
life much easier to live you know what I
mean right
and that's I mean that's the reason for
what happened last year she got off of
her Med she didn't like how they made
her feel and you know she got off of
them and then that happened okay and you
know I've really tried to bend on be on
her you can't you can't man you can't be
on her you're not her dad
you're somebody who loves her
yeah and it's hard because you
the longer I well that's a parenting
analogy I don't do that
the more you intervene
and confirm to her that she has broken
and damaged and unable to care for
herself in any capacity
the more you come in and try to take
over and quote unquote be on her about
taking her stuff and doing the right the
more you do that the more her ability to
get with her doctor and to follow her
doctor's plans and to build that
resilience and that muscle and just
atrophies over time
the helplessness increases
does that make sense
no yeah that definitely makes sense
um what what often
not always and again I I would want to
talk to her and make sure she's got the
right psychiatric care
often the greatest gift you can give
somebody
who is struggling with mental health
with their mental health challenges
particularly in something like
schizophrenia something like bipolar one
of the schizoaffective disorders is that
you be very very well
meaning you set the mark for I am never
going to miss a day of exercise I'm
gonna get plugged into a spiritual
Community I'm going to have my own
friends I'm going to eat as best as I
can I'm gonna have where I'm going to do
work that matters I'm not going to owe a
bunch of people money so I'm not
stressed all the time
and what you're doing is you're creating
an environment of peace that often
somebody with bipolar doesn't even
understand it's different air
it's a it's a purity of oxygen they've
never breed before
and instead of you bringing your chaos
to an already chaotic environment and
trying to demand Clarity in that chaotic
environment doesn't work
all right see what I'm saying
yes yeah and it feels like let me put it
this way and this is going to sound
harsh
um
if you said I'm going to love you every
day but I'm not going to call you and
check up on you every day and see if you
took your meds I'm going to trust you
and
I know that you've been diagnosed with X
or Y in this relationship you we cannot
lie to one another
period we have to tell the truth or I
have to ask myself hard questions about
being married to somebody who doesn't
tell the truth
you cannot hit me you cannot go off on
three-day disappear for three days or
five days and end up with somebody that
we used to know and then just roll it up
like
that might be a function of your
disorder that might be a function of
some of your manic behaviors that is not
something I'm going to tolerate in this
relationship so if you want to be in
this relationship with me
you're gonna have to be extra
um direct with your psychiatrist get to
be extra intentional about taking your
medication you have to be extra
intentional about being honest with me
you see what I'm saying I'm taking
bipolar off the table I'm dealing with
these behaviors because what you're
going to do is you're going to you're
going to end up her dad
right that's exactly how I feel right
and that's not your job your job is to
love her
be her partner not her father
and you can also find yourself after
your dad passed away
suddenly the world feels a lot less a
lot less in control it feels out of
control feels chaotic and Mayhem and
dude I'm going to tighten my grip on
this one relationship that I got left
and what you end up doing is you tighten
your grip so much you strangle the whole
thing
yeah I mean that's exactly how I feel
like I feel like what I'm doing right
now
it's not working
do what it's not working
no not at all I just I just feel like
I'm
pushing her away when I'm not meaning to
yes
yes and it's just falling apart right
underneath my nose you know yes so
here's the exercise for you
okay stop looking at her like she's some
sort of dysfunctional broke down car
that you've gotta
walk nine miles to a gas station with
one of those rad guests red gas cans to
fill up with gas
she is a person a friend your girlfriend
you love her
she'll probably laugh like crazy when
she's up I bet she is a rocket ship to
be around huh
very much so yeah like the funnest my
favorite friends I've got are my bipolar
friends when they're up they're a riot
dude it's incredible
um and it makes me forget sometimes the
totality of our relationship
because when things are bad they're real
real bad
yeah right exactly so
I want you to stop looking like she
can't think for herself and do for
herself and exist for herself and I want
you to have a crazy conversation ask her
this this question
um say hey I've been trying to act like
your dad and I don't know how this
happened I'm just trying to love you and
I'm a good Texas male and so I try to
Love by
um dominating and I'm not gonna do that
anymore I love you too much
how can I best love you right now
ask her that question
okay what do you need from me
and then tell her I'm used to telling
you to take your meds every day on that
you know that I'm not going to do that
that's between you and your doctor I'll
go with you to the appointments if you'd
like
um but at the end of the day you've got
to want to be well
[Music]
and for her meds might be a part of her
life forever they might just be
um great cool
I'm not going to lose sleep over that
we're just going to make that a part of
our life and if they start to make her
not feel good then we're going to find
different ones we're not just going to
quit because we know what happens when
we quit right but again she's got to
want that
and you're gonna have to practice not
trying to Lord over but you're gonna
have to practice being with
and that means you're gonna have to have
boundaries that when you show up and
she's seven beers in
you say I told you I I'm not interested
in being around you when you're drunk
um we you say things I say things I'm
stepping out of this if you go I'm gonna
that you're you're gonna make those
choices I love you with all my heart but
I'm also going to hold these boundaries
right right that's exactly how that goes
right
yep yes or she calls you at 2AM and says
I want you to come over and I need to be
with you right now and you say I've got
to sleep because I got work
um doesn't mean they don't love you it
means that I gotta take care of myself
if you don't come over right now I'm
gonna call so
if you do that that's great you're
opting out of a relationship with me but
I'm going back to bed I love you
right
here's the other side Chris
she might call that guy
she might get super super drunk
and you might have to call 9-1-1 but you
can't be your dad
right
right you don't like that do you
no it's just not that I don't like it
it's just it's gonna be something that I
just have to work on and
something we're gonna have to talk about
and
um we we got into therapy and
we were doing great and then another
episode happened and our therapist was
just like
you know I don't know enough about your
about her situation I think y'all should
find somebody else
and kind of just left us hanging there
so you know we're gonna look into
somebody else get back into therapy and
just figure this out okay
um
at the end of the day all only person on
planet Earth you can control is you your
thoughts and your actions
your boundaries and your choices that's
it that's it that's it that's it that's
it that's it
that's it
so make the decision to ask yourself
what are the things I need to do to be
well
what are my boundaries forget the
bipolar diagnosis
what are my boundaries you cannot tell
me you hate me you cannot tell me to go
blank myself you cannot
um sleep with somebody that's not like
that's that's you can't get super high
or super coked up and run around the
neighborhood like you can't do these
things
I won't I won't be in partnership with
somebody I won't commit my life
romantically to somebody I won't try to
build a life with somebody who is unable
to be Integris be a person of fidelity
and I will love you but I can't be your
dad
and that's going to be hard hard hard
for you I think all this starts with you
asking her that one magic question how
can I best love you
because the way I'm trying to have loved
you for the last five years isn't
working let's I want to try something
new
and you my brother are gonna have to
practice
opening your hand up
saying I love you and here's my boundary
appreciate your heart man
gotta do something different this time
and yes go find another therapist one
that will stick with you guys and that
no better knows how to teach people the
skills of loving one another when
somebody's got bipolar it's out there it
exists you can't have a happy marriage
just kind of work at it